they invited inhabitants rooms box they
have all she wanted my heart does not
like I jump I drove the wrong way
Oh am i a trapeze trying passes guys now
I went the wrong way
okay that makes sense
[Music]
nobody's felt already am i hide in the
house alright thanks guys I will take
take your advice
I better hide in the house he is over
here I'll help you out of this one
I'm not gonna hide a baby I want a gun
I wanna shoot me so it's Franco
I know what I think like that was like
yours what you like what to kill him but
you can't this game isn't about
beginning
okay how do I get your hand
oh thank you very much right
I made it to a half this is from breast
there's my battery but oh okay
everything come in
[Music]
yes he's coming
[Music]
is grunting so be patient okay lowly
there's like flashes of his flashlight
but no it's still kind of nearby should
I do it guys I go out there he's left
oh no no not now not now Oh Jimmy people
me okay I don't want to go out there's
people right outside oh my gosh yeah
okay it's gonna be so much we can do
this
[Music]
oh hi hey I think I can smell again
hiding it
yeah oh my god hey you're dead good look
okay yeah I'm bad here oh yeah this old
guard is gonna save it fee fie foe fum
yo go-go-go golem run what is that
okay
what I know no God while I'm glad in a
gaggle I'm dreaming come on [ __ ]
right ah yeah
okay suggest on the board I'm sorry I
have to do this you should have loved me
you should have helped me Jesus forgive
me I don't know what to do I'm so so
sorry Jessica wait I remember this
[Music]
he will shield if he had a kid come
early yeah yeah and because everyone
Chris Jent they were like uh-uh I'm
fluent when we were oh look back in the
fourth grade hearing others could get
force yeah
school wasn't the best time for me okay
so my battery disc in this injury
batteries
schools on a three-bean
especially when it is encounter then
again I went
not me to go to play we might have to
walk towards you face my fear this is
the dream world so
ah yeah
[Applause]
I don't know what
you joined the hall
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
again in the bathroom oh I can laugh is
it real creepy because I need to find
more country it's a million because I
use this to like try and find batteries
and dark places but then you end up just
using a half more because there's never
any frickin batteries okay like a creepy
room anyway I know in the
focus and then I hate to feel good when
I know can hide in a lot of places
because that means that I'm not safe
let me die or died random guys probably
noticed by now I run and I hide it
Oh
try and not be you this opal is you
cannot see what you
we're AMA high school
go into the game ah again
[Applause]
your images the odds are no not a cutie
didn't aim no no yeah well they'll do it
if they find you out here wait I've got
a friend come on who are you my name's
Ethan let it mean Olivia you're one of
them and which side are you want my
ain't not trying to kill you
I've been on for you too much to keep
the faith but you're not one of those
other I'm not feeling too good Ethan
here hold up say squat my wife gots go I
can't see anything to cast out didn't
complain would not
first himself my enemy and she not were
15
I'm sorry Sigma grandson what baby she
put her was my fleet in a craft night
exclude rebellion to the job what
wait wait - you did ask
CSUN huges does did he say that he split
the belly of his store and so my job is
to run from the Lakeland I want you to
return my whole life
your problem knows Jane Doe sorry your
daughter she was eight months pregnant
blonde hair cut like a poison yeah what
do you know you say 'no it's why we came
here is she all right
please tell me she's okay she's fine oh
oh thank god Oh
Lydon you know I need some help and
countries you have any batteries oh you
really okay don't be such a man take
care of you
appreciate it seems to be no battery sir
I'm disappointed in you
sorry you select here I'll keep you safe
you do it down here and he'll he's gone
through huge advantages I don't need
Wow I'm glad we made it friend makes me
feel happy
to me
[Music]
I had nothing Magister cannot pass in
fact I line
I can't Papa's gospel at a hundred times
uh I think it is we're outside work
traffic don't need your help refining
camel told her about me not questions
even how other you can hide the top your
daughter yes baby give me call him
suppose you know I can explain
oh great because of me AB and AB and a
man died here we go you didn't give me
up to her even though she such a good
friends thank you even though it just
went yesterday that now I walk over your
body to say thank you sorry
Oh didn't we do that one
as I remember in the press outlast if
you set in blood would be on your shoes
maybe that was just some carpet Hey
yeah cool it's little touches like that
but I enjoy about games anyway and take
this with us
yeah that's right you do have a mastery
off Ethan
I appreciate you okay
[Music]
something in between that is people
so it's really put me on edge oh my god
hi how did we not yet I think I don't
really want to be seen although I'm
gonna go
give that lady how his life is that okay
right so he wasn't impressed all right I
can chill out with Lana because of seems
to be a little village here so probably
needs a shop and hide a barrel [ __ ]
great
I
dead people everywhere yes brick in
bondage I don't need those and he cut
please okay
chapter five something something
something is and it's a girl
I let despite the pain of the whole
Bella as a cross section of a sphere of
Allah and this is their appearance since
about Jesus and their faces were
innumerable and that's where they're
faded in the next moment apocalypse in
the moment that's all of their faces
were the sex organs of angels what what
and the Mayans are follow the bonfire
and flavor voices singing in Beauty so
their faces were all of these things at
once and there brings joined in the
flash okay that's weird
always on the lookout batteries
I was so lost as I went into that
contract
[Music]
who pretty
place you download online
ah lovely trailer blood that she left a
bowl what the hell
haha yeah okay oh god oh this place I
remember from the demo it's dead pig mr.
pig is dead pig is dead pig oh now
you're facing the wrong way you idiot
right okay exit no one's here did that
for no reason well done you okay I feel
like I need to go up here okay okay okay
okay okay
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah now hi hello too
many people
this I can do you see audio things are
ready I guess out yells you don't know
oh yeah he's like right now
yeah it looks right yeah okay now yes
wait Oh
I hate winking to move though we would
take so long I repeat whatever right
okay and well there's someone here
there's someone here that someone here
someone here and I don't know why did it
oh it's really coming for you everywhere
I go
guys what am I going I'm just going
around a circle and no frickin clue like
while I'm supposed to be doing some
batteries are way out v lovely I don't
want to die the chapel somebody there
will know where they take it away
brilliant so where the hell is it over
there 20 of that cos you have that
running this much [ __ ] problem like I
just run everywhere okay yeah come on go
go go go
no no no no no no man I'm going
everything is so freakin stressful
please don't chase me Oh bull what are
we gonna open the school ah as long as
you're okay right
where's she went hi okay fine I
appreciate that
[Music]
okay saving those who keep using hi yep
this is a nice view I can see him
perfectly you can leave it is gonna
leave it abuser tell us oh okay look
here it's okay
[Music]
no okay dudas new disease easy do you
use this Timmy come in here just a me
nope
you saw me hi peep it's nowhere for me
so goal Oh yellow right now to the left
too many students to the students if the
students owe you
hi know by me I'm gonna do my cycle
again please I'm so glad you don't help
him find me
Wow
and then jump on it and then get one is
who you want on and out okay
[Music]
another day mummified body Thanks
[Music]
wait am i first looks for fat trees oh
there's a little three more were sent
today to live among the doll start their
school their solve two flawed to
disguise they had seven children between
them all of whom publicly not had sent
with the others into my foster care I
now have more than forty orphans under
my wing who love me desperately as only
a child as only can a child abandoned by
the parents they thought where is
natural and dependable a fact as the
great rival Sun and I love them as I
will never have children of my own
emerald as I must love you
my god leave them to I will be there
this conference think Oh what do these
dreams mean all those a dream okay all
this
oh my god cries I'm sorry
oh yeah that that's not pleasant
nice
yes laughs
well me for a love that place we catch
the chapel now
solo Christ make me ready farther not
drive money salvation
let's bother not inflict a fright not a
price let me drink your wine by the
CeBIT I gave me vision angel of God
lend me your sword time Jesus hear my
prayer heal me in your grams feet Li
close to you defend me from a rich old
world and ready me for the devil's hour
in the Fellowship of Temple page that I
might defend your creation you give me
rest
nah
gotta appreciate a good luck okay
we've done on the copper battery back in
school
I'll wait what was that
okay that was definitely unexpected
so we're gonna get teleported somewhere
again all bad just God you look away
another deaf person
okay
climb up any of these rocks
cut there's already blood on the wall
where someone's tried to do this already
not instill me with her okay okay
did it battery for my efforts I should
really reload but I know to see
oh gosh wait
okay I'm reloading in church no some
kind of heretic temple oh yeah
is that an upside-down cross and a
normal course together yes
we can make it
yep I mean that's really creepy but it's
really cool as well if you can make
fellas creepy freaky
huh great Wi-Fi go and press open hey
let me get brother
frikken rockets to get off the rock
[Music]
what she's gone what she was just like
walking into the darkness such a nice
thing to do
okay
Meneely at the chapel not I'm gonna try
and make it to the shuttle belly
[Music]
mother and
he's little noises series bring me out
petals
no more children's dead not says there's
no sin in such infanticide as all our
soldiers in God's army
Martha's fallen on the build in defiance
of the Archfiend all those babies with
slits throats and charred flesh through
waiting immaculate for us in Paradise
have enough also says that our sins find
us in our dreams but my dreams are
nothing for the matter of my children
and I wait laughing and crowd and often
wet in the involuntary loss of sleep I
woke this morning thinking I was wetted
with the blood of a child flip broke but
it was the wetness of my own making the
others are having similar dreams we have
dug a tunnel that we may meet in secret
we gather and share our visions and
wonder in their meaning I felt
increasingly this is a message
you definitely what like this thing
that's disgusting
ha
debauchery
sorry Debrecen I'm not sorry probably
freaks just like everyone else here so
no I know that I avoid sudden slit his
throat
God is afraid because your God is no
cultural your God is your own ego bomb
bomb bomb falls and embarrassments FAL
all vowel I do not ask that you join us
I tell you you will join us because I
love is greater than you could ever
imagine
my God is never at all he's true he's
here in every room to actually the child
will [ __ ] tear this world to
everlasting boy okay he's not very much
better is he children in the spectrum of
slitting throats under
okay that might be an elevator up there
isn't it cut off gotta have a generator
see of course the generate dimension
tricks everyone parking now another
lovely screen
yes
goodbye
imagine downstairs wait this way came
from
now just see underground place if there
was v-tach
she can hurt me if I get closer
okay I'm going this way
more than people left the yes
being comes slowly going on tour
self-love yeah
however your practice
is great and not is
No hi brain not Oh
I didn't kill me thank you
I don't think nothing's your Redemption
oh hey how dark this whole place is nice
he'll give me any batteries folks Jesus
why don't the DOS approaches me I'm
sorry
okay myself
[Music]
- nothing in this house evening I
happily break windows really big right
are you it is like a nice friendly
present breathing man sorry okay I will
be doing my hair again Jesus get the
elevator working
don't hurt me please lady I just wanted
to hear your story to win why aren't
they trying to kill me a very confused
but I mean happy oh okay you're trying
to kill me please cute oh oh oh
they're dead stop that
oh this way this way Hesse Oh sighs
visited that I die today hi hi people
chill chill don't drown
the chill oh great
no I need bandages or email nope
okay cool Simon I need to talk to you in
the deepest secret cause of your knowing
what I need to talk to you in the
deepest secret cause of your knowing
Bianca choose me I hope you know I do
not trade any more words strictly
needful when we make the trip in the
Damned world for gasoline and
electricals and other freshness
necessary necessaries you're like some
of these necessaries on to work
necessities would be I do these people
running over backwards hey bender fun
day back to the elevator
Hey
okay
no thank you we are the stars of a true
failing this Ava's displays this
breaking pause of scare the children of
hell but also my salvation side is
Braden matter Sam okay when she's
talking about god she's very much
involved in what she's saying
[Music]
don't want to do any of it I don't want
to go back
so this one
Gilligan
so to process
I don't know I keep on asking you guys
oh geez the ashwin in my eye that was
pretty cool
this way um hi no I am because no don't
know why I press the crowd when you win
get it give him mine
oh so that's what I'm running back into
that houses then let me in as soon as
you hit me I die okay
where this way Shh Jesus come on
okay okay okay here yeah let's go this
way this way to do this way
oh yeah
what are you two dressed to dreadful
blue dress for okay did it show 59
school okay oh my heart I'm gonna hear
now can I quit now as well
just
tell me
what we lost
[Music]
he's coming is it a doctor guy that's
for free ah I remember this
Oh
mommy - OH
ghetto get in I didn't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think I died here July I think I died
here last time I met something comes our
me I know it does I know it does I know
it does no it does look happen okay hi
oh no nothing huh
okay why is it suddenly so quiet guys
[Music]
all right all right just come come
ran off oh god yes
[Music]
I scare remember what we can
fight why didn't I record her I'm an
idiot
aha no if this is the same as a demo I
am NOT going to like this next bum bah
oh oh mama mama Bam Bam Bam Bam just
follow the blood and run
[Music]
something like super good
oh okay down there go oh
or oh my god am I going to work from
Oh Oh I don't know what's happening oh
right
ah okay yeah I don't have time oh my god
he's right behind me
go go no just go stop yeah cease fire
whoa nice day so please Bart
okay
I'm not say
I know I'm not safe
watching me
[Applause]
I'm gone gone gone gone gone just try
and get past your buddy alright see you
later
oh my head heads I didn't dream in too
much I'm ready for my answer all of my
head said let's open this bleeding wait